hey guys Kelly and Dave we are having
some coffee shooting the [ __ ] and when
we're shooting the [ __ ] we're doing it
publicly right all right is this
publicly this is being recorded look
shooting of [ __ ] yes and it is going to
be sent out to the masses through ones
and zeros everywhere yeah it's very
matrix e and that was making me think I
want to talk about privacy because it's
one of the things that we talked about
on the show all the time it's been a
very weird year for privacy because
between the NSA between hacking which is
going on right now with this Sony
situation between leaking of emails and
you know we've how we found out about
the CIA know sext oh and there's a sext
photos yes sex photos are before the SEC
celebrities yeah their personal boobs
went out yeah the vagina pictures and
all that other stuff it's been a weird
year for privacy privacy was something
that at one time but you say hello we
used to have it right new direct there
was like a psycho there was a certain
expectation of privacy you know even
when when I'm not just talking about
before we got online but for the first
ten years of being online yes we thought
your emails when you would send an email
to someone it would be like a private
letter to Scotland you didn't think
someone might someday read that I mean I
literally remember when i first got
online I was on like AOL when it was
still on a CD and I had to dial up and
all that you kids can read about that on
the Wikipedia um but I literally
remember that you your emails would
disappear after a few days right and
then Google came in with Gmail and kept
everything all the time and then they
scan it for so that they can figure out
what ads which i always think is
hilarious because if i write an email
about transformers and I'm talking about
Megatron I get ads for transformers that
are really pissing me off your whole
google thing yeah it's a lot it's a lot
so my question to you yes after all this
big leaden is what expectation of
privacy do you have any more at any
level because it seems like it's just
it's not only the government right it's
not only NSA but now we know the hackers
and the releasing of the emails a
private citizen Z yeah I guess there's a
difference between legal expectation and
kind of real life expectation you know
so legally I expect some privacy i
expect laws to work and that my private
emails are private and that people
be using them against me for things and
if you hacked them and it's a it's a
illegal act of some kind right wait but
you've been poor you gone isn't that
even the problem that so then they can
maybe go after the hacker that yeah but
if you think about what's happening with
Sony right now right the hackers did it
whether you agree with the hackers or
not and you whether you agree with Sony
executives decisions on things and
financials blah blah blah but now all
these websites are just picking up their
emails because there's salacious stuff
in them yeah I'm pushing it out there so
there's so many levels like there's the
legal part as you're saying but then
there's this other part that's the part
that feels gross to me and it is gross
and it's I mean you know but it's been
happening for over a hundred years I
mean yellow journalism is yellow
journalism it's tabloid journalism and
here we have tabloid online spreading of
stuff if I would even call it journalism
at this point I don't think there is
journalism anymore sad thing yeah we
should do so segment on what is
journalist yeah I don't even know
anymore yeah I don't know anymore either
I think they're still teaching it at
universities but I don't know if
anyone's paying attention yeah uh so
yeah I mean and I don't think I really
even expects I I don't know is there any
privacy anymore on lie i don't know and
then i'm also a person who does things
like this i have a podcast i go online
so I'm saying hey part of my
conversations in life or an online thing
I think that the the things going to
swing the other way I think people are
going to get really pissed off about
this eventually hopefully soon yeah and
start demanding that there are some real
teeth in these laws and that we can go
after people and that we do get to have
something private or maybe we're all
going to start really creating and
demanding some barriers online again I
don't know that it's it is I mean the
fact that these people's emails are
going all over the place I mean well it
was like the Donald cause it'll get eggs
you I'm Alistair those were private
texts is that what it was a text they
were private phone calls yeah it may be
that this is a privacy these are private
no matter what if you think the guy is
the biggest Nimrod in the world he has
the right to say that so is that is is
that the other part of this that people
that doesn't really get into the
equation that people's principles seem
to be very attached to exactly what's
happening at that moment yes so
something like the Donald Cerrone
of course he's racist he's awful
horrible at the end of the day it's good
of course that he doesn't own an NBA
team which has you know night let's say
to eighty percent black late to have an
opinion and to say those things right so
so our expectation of his privacy is
also couched in him owning a public yes
so there's so many legends day freaky
now the whole the whole pc thing on
campuses you know Bill Maher not being
able to go to Berkeley to speak or the
other letting it now they're letting him
yeah that's frightening that that pc
stuff really frightens me and that's
coming from the left and I'm generally a
lefty personal ft but um headband that's
a lefty thing right exactly um but I'm
also a First Amendment proponent I mean
huge huge force Amendment proponent and
almost an absolutist I really believe
that everyone should have the right to
an opinion and say what they believe is
that makes a healthy conversation
remember conversation we used to have
that I don't have it online media
reality jailer now you have the right to
free speech not the right not to be
offended yeah everyone seems to think
that you were right right not to be
offended right I interview I had an
interview with Dick Cavett and he was
amazing and he was like a free speech
loves to offend people and you know he's
in his 80s and was like yes I just you
know I those are my those are my heroes
people who are willing to offend yeah
there's so much here I mean we could
talk about race between free speech
between the web right about the whole
Sony thing is what if this is just a big
PR scheme oh my god would that be great
I'm going to well you know what I'm
probably not gonna see a movie the movie
looks like [ __ ] anyway so yeah you know
when they're promoting it like they are
it's not very good yeah but they're
going this is the best thing ever look
we can replace the executives right if
it gets at that point and if north korea
bombs of a movie house oh my god right
then we have bigger problems already
anyway what do you guys think do you
have any manageable reasonable
expectation of privacy let us know in
the comments right down below